if you ask the former Intel and law
enforcement Chiefs slamming president
Trump they'll pretty much say they're
doing it to save the country and our
standing in the world but in reality
they may be doing the exact opposite and
playing right into our enemy's hands
joining me now with more is New York
congressman Lee Zeldin
he's a member of the House Foreign
Affairs Committee and Jameel Jaffer is
the director of national security law
and policy program at George Mason
University gentlemen let's get right
into it playing into our enemy's hands
Russia wants to undermine America's
faith in its system or constitutional
republic and congressman it's working in
some quarters are they playing into his
hands into Putin's hands yeah absolutely
you're doing Russia's work for them
you're doing our adversaries work for
them when internally you have people
whether they're inside our government or
they are now recently they're outside of
our government seeking to undermine our
own country our own democratically
elected government so you're absolutely
right that's a real concern that I have
and it's really one of the reasons why
John Brennan shouldn't have a security
clearance you should make an example of
him and if you do any type of it an
Intel analyst you analyze him and you
look at just emotionally mentally
whether or not he has it all together
and also whether he understands rules
right now when he's accusing the
president of high crimes and
misdemeanors after the Helsinki and the
Helsinki summit and Senators treason if
you do an analysis on John Brennan it's
important that we're not only making an
example of them we're sending a strong
message but we actually take away
security clearance because that why you
have a right to First Amendment you do
not have a right to a security clearance
especially when you're as unhinged as
this man is right now all right so let's
go right to it and this is video from
CNN Jim Sciuto asking the question about
Putin Sharon Brennan and the soil and
the security clearances places you have
a president firing
a former leader of the intelligence
community and citing the Russia
investigation does Putin cheer this kind
of thing of course he does it's just
more chaos more kind of dismantling of
the u.s. system of the transatlantic
alliance you know at this point the kind
of sanctions doesn't matter it's all
about shaking up our system taking it
down a notch instead of bringing Russia
I Jamil your reaction to that well look
David the problem here is that this is a
problem the president creation he didn't
need a strip right into security
clearance Brendan was doing a good
enough job on his own making himself
look partisan the president's now
continue this conversation made the
narrative horse got in the way of his
own message about tax cuts regulatory
reform conservative judges the
president's created this problem for
himself he doesn't need to do this
he's a stay on message and how worried
about John Brennan and John Bray was
doing a good enough job on his own
making himself irrelevant all right so
Lee there's been some critique about the
method in which this played out that the
president according to some could have
just done it let it happen not give John
Brennan even a bigger megaphone but the
president said he's elevated him what do
you say well first of all I don't think
John Brennan should have gotten a
security clearance in the first place
and this is a man who admitted to voting
Communist Party for president States and
now fast-forward to currently he's
seeking to monetize his position as
former CIA director and as I mentioned
earlier he has become unhinged for the
President of the United States to make
an example of him he's sending a strong
message to others that there are rules
that you do have a right to first if
your First Amendment freedom of speech
you do not have a right to a security
clearance and you also need to follow
the rules of the United States
government you can't set your own rules
of what's right and wrong because one of
the biggest threats if not the biggest
threat that we have seen historically as
far as access to classified information
is when you have an individual gone
rogue who is setting their own rules and
deciding that their own moral compass is
one that supersedes it overcomes any
type of guidance that the government
puts out on John Brennan and anyone like
him so I think it's important to very
publicly make an example that this
conduct by this man right now is is what
it's exactly what disqualifies you
will result in losing your security
clearance I think it's great these
making a public example of this man all
right Jamil the public example how does
this play out in the political world the
intel chiefs their letters will this
last will it have any effect as you see
it yeah I mean look the problem David is
that the congressman is right to make
the point that maybe you wanna make
example somebody right the problem is by
making an example John Brennan the
president's now got bipartisan
opposition from all his intelligence
officials 60 former CIA officers it's
going poorly for the president this is
not working this is an unforced error it
was a tactical mistake could have
strategic consequences the presidents
got to get out his own way and stay on
message and not worry about the rush
investigation not worry about Bob Mahler
that investors gonna happen the
presidential folks on his own message
and focus on that and listen to his
aides who were telling him by the way
stop doing the stuff this is not good
business all right gentlemen thank you
very much